uno de los cambios más llamativos es la
repartición equitativa de ganancias en
los mundiales sin importar cuál de las
dos selecciones tenga un mayor desempeño
de qué se trata la medida
bueno muchas gracias pero lo más
importante de este fuero de hoy lo que
lo hace único es que es el primero en el
cual se incluyen los premios por ifa de
los de los campeonatos del mundo de la
danza masculinos como femeninos y esto
ninguna otra selección ninguna otra
federación va incluido por la diferencia
tan amplia que existe entre los premios
de un mundial femenino y uno masculino
ahora cuál es la diferencia entre el
fútbol femenino y otros deportes de
conjunto como el baloncesto o el
software por ejemplo en los que las
mujeres son tan o más destacadas que los
hombres porque en esos casos no se ha
llegado a esta paridad
bueno yo creo que el impacto que tiene
el fútbol como deporte global el que se
practica en todo el mundo es la
diferencia no siempre el fútbol es el
deporte que intenta romper barreras y el
resto de deportes pues le pueden seguir
y pueden ayudar en este impacto positivo
no como es el caso del fútbol femenino
también es verdad que en eeuu el fútbol
femenino es un deporte muchísimo más
visible y que se practica mucho más que
por ejemplo en europa no con lo cual
este acuerdo era bastante importante
también para ellas para los futbolistas
eeuu es un caso bien particular porque
su selección femenina genera más
ganancias que la masculina tiene esta
decisión histórica el potencial para
impulsar un cambio en otras federaciones
o incluso en otros deportes las mujeres
cada vez brillan más y para no ir muy
lejos las jugadoras del barcelona están
llenando estadios
si efectivamente en la diferencia que
hay principalmente en el resto del mundo
en el fútbol femenino oa nivel global
también incluyendo eeuu es deficitario
se alimenta del fútbol masculino y en
concreto del mundial de las selecciones
absolutas masculinas entonces esta
medida con este nuevo acuerdo en el que
se crea como una bolsa en el que se
incluye están todas las ganancias del
masculino como el femenino para nutrir
ambas selecciones es innovadora es única
y puede ser un ejemplo para que otras
federaciones se animen a invertir de
esta manera y a tratar de compartir esas
ganancias hasta que los premios
evidentemente pues sean igualitarios
señora volver en el caso viene desde
2016 cuando las jugadoras de la
selección femenina en paradas en la ley
de igualdad salarial que prohíbe la
discriminación de sueldo por sexo
presentaron una demanda porque soccer
tardó hasta este 2022 para resolver la
situación de las jugadoras y cuéntanos
qué cambia ahora para ellas
bueno cambia todo ha tardado muchísimo
porque evidentemente es una negociación
colectiva y que en este caso además
también afectaba a la selección
masculina no entonces la importancia de
este acuerdo que sea con ambas
selecciones es vital y el haber tardado
tanto tiempo es en poner en común todos
los puntos porque hablamos del tema de
los premios y el salario pero es un
acuerdo muy global que incluye otro tipo
de conceptos como es el tema de también
de las instalaciones de los hoteles de
los viajes que pop y hace fundamental
que que se haya firmado ahora para
iniciar el siguiente periodo hasta el
mundial femenino del año que viene